[Music]
what's your ambition take a second pause
and think about it
what's an ambition that you have for
yourself whether it's to become the next
blockchain investor to launch that
startup you've always dreamed of or to
become the next Secretary of Defense
whatever it might be imagine how amazing
you're going to feel when you realize
that ambition now let's just say I
arbitrarily decide to draw a line down
the room I'll include Geordi in the line
on this side I tell all of you on this
side of the room but actually just
because I decided you don't get to
realize your ambition that because you
sat in that seat you don't get the
opportunity to pursue your dreams
imagine how much it would suck to have
your ambition taken away from you this
is what happens to women all over the
world let me walk you across the world
for a second to a rural part of Kenya
it's a scorching hot day and I'm sitting
under a shady tree talking to a bunch of
girls and asking them that same question
that I just asked all of you what's your
ambition the girls respond to be a
doctor to be a lawyer to be an astronaut
just like you and me these girls
imagine a bright future for themselves
yet as my conversation with them
continues I begin to realize that
they're not going to realize their
ambition that because of factors beyond
their control they won't have the
opportunity to pursue their dreams one
of the girls Dorothy who I got to know
well during this time tells me that
every morning she wakes up at 4:00 a.m.
before school and she walks two hours to
a well gets water and carries it home
for her family after school she's the
one who's expected to take care of her
younger siblings and
cook dinner for the family while
Dorothy's brothers are studying her and
millions of girls like her around the
world are expected to take on household
work when money is tight parents send a
clear signal by sending their sons to
school but asking their daughters to
stay home and when girls do make it to
the classroom they have to listen to
their teachers make comments like don't
do math like a girl girls are constantly
told implicitly and explicitly that
their ambitions are not as important as
their brothers and what does this mean
this means that less than 15 percent of
the girls that I met that summer will
graduate from high school their
ambitions of being doctors lawyers and
astronauts will get crushed and instead
they'll get married young give birth to
multiple children and then they'll ask
their daughters to stay home and help
with household tasks their daughters
will become the next generation of women
who have to carry the water this is the
heartbreaking reality of so many of the
girls who I met in mohuru Bay Kenya
seven years ago at that time I was
thinking what some of you might be
thinking right now this is extremely sad
but it's also kind of expected in a
low-income and rural place like mohuru
Bay I left a situation feeling totally
helpless I wanted to make a difference
but I didn't know how several years
later I decided to apply to Stanford its
Graduate School of Business
when I got the infamous call from
Derrick Bolton I was elated I was so
excited
and I thought that at such a
well-resourced and elite place like the
GSB I would find my answers to these
questions I also assumed that for the
first time in my life I would be in an
environment where women's ambition was
not only encouraged it was expected
however I haven't always found that to
be the case let me take you to an uber
ride couple months ago with a couple of
classmates maybe some of you in the room
we're riding back home after a late
night of BPL so another night at the
patio there's a female classmate and too
close guy friends who are in the car and
we started joking around about being
single at the GSB some of you will also
be able to relate to that we were
talking about how rough it can be and
those questions that constantly plague
us should I bring a notebook on my
ambigú date at our buckle tomorrow can
one of you please create an excel
tracker so I can know who's still single
but then all of a sudden the
conversation turns to something I didn't
expect my female classmate turned to me
and said Sadhna I don't think I'm gonna
keep working once I get married I doubt
I'll find a husband who will support my
career ambition I was shocked
this is Stanford's Graduate School of
Business
she went on to explain that because
women are more nurturing it only makes
sense that she's the one who's expected
to take care of her kids and it turns
out that my friends experience is not an
anomaly a recent Harvard Business Review
study shows that single MBA women
continue to downplay their ambition they
continue to feel like there is a
trade-off between ambition and marriage
on the first day of an MBA program these
students were asked to state their
career preferences when they were told
that their responses would be shared
with their male classmates they said
that they wanted to make $20,000 less
they also said that they're less able
and willing to lead
shouldn't this concern everybody in the
room we want women to be smart loving
nurturing but never ambitious to be
honest with you I even hesitated to give
a talk on female ambition because I
thought one of you in the room would
hear it and think that I was too
ambitious and then I realized this is
the problem research also shows that
women in the u.s. spend 25 hours per
week on household tasks women that are
working and their male counterparts in
the same professional tier spend only 10
hours per week on household tasks so
what shows up in the homes and
classrooms in Kenya actually shows up
right here at the GSB even in the United
States women carry the water no matter
where we are and no matter how rich how
poor there is a common theme all across
the development curve we fail to support
women's ambition it's easy to hear this
talk and to not realize the personal
implications of it to be honest I didn't
realize it until it happened to me I
recently found myself in a situation
where I was told that there was no room
for my ambition I was in a three-year
relationship with a guy who I loved and
wanted to marry yet time and time again
in the relationship there was so many
subtle and some not so subtle signs that
my ambition was a problem my partner's
fear but because I wanted to have a
career I wouldn't make a good mother or
thoughts in my own head that if I just
turned down my consulting offer after
business school maybe I could make him
love me more but then in that moment I
suddenly thought back to Dorothy
and all of the girls who had met in
Kenya I thought of my 9 year old niece
who loves Bill and I have a science guy
and wants to be a scientist when she
grows up with their faces in my mind I
finally gathered the courage to leave
the relationship rather than to leave my
ambition behind in writing this talk I
finally have realized the answer to my
question I finally know what we can do
to help those girls in Kenya and it
starts with making a change right here
at the GSB if you're a woman don't let
someone else's expectations dictate your
level of ambition don't downplay your
dreams for somebody else and if you're a
man you play a huge role in all this you
have an amazing opportunity to help
women realize their ambition don't be
afraid of ambitious women we don't bite
I promise date ambitious women marry
them celebrate their accomplishments in
your future workplace encourage women to
be ambitious and support their careers
and more tactically when you're in a
domestic partnership make sure you're
taking on your share of childcare and
household work only then we all work
together and balance the load can we
make sure that women aren't the only
ones carrying the water thank you
[Applause]
[Music]